-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-winning comedian
and actor you know from shows
like "Extras" and "The Office."
The third and final season
of his show
"After Life"
is streaming now on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-[ Air horn blares ]
-Aah!
-[ Laughing ]
Oh, my God. Oh, my God.
-Prat!
-[ Laughing ]
Maybe life
is still worth living!
Oh, my God.
-That's not funny, actually.
-Wow. I disagree.
-Please welcome back to the
show our friend Ricky Gervais!
Hello, Ricky!
-Hello.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, Ricky, I want to ask
first about the clip.
Is that a functional air horn?
-It was real,
and that was the first take,
and we nailed it,
but I did it again about another
10 times for my own amusement.
So the actor
got more and more injured,
and that's obviously
a real laugh
because someone falling over
and hurting themselves is funny.
That is comedy to me.
-The last time
you were here in studio,
we talked about the first season
of this show, "After Life,"
and I complimented you
on what a wonderful job
you did casting out this show.
It is such a -- Even though
you were torturing them
and making them fall down
and hurt themselves,
this is really a wonderful group
of people that you put together.
-Yeah. I mean, the good thing
about this is,
once you've been around
for a while,
I can cast before I write it.
So when you first write
something, you send it off,
you get it greenlit,
and then you have to cast.
You're trying to work out
who to do it.
And the second season
is always the best,
because you know
who you're writing for.
You know the physicality.
You know what they're good at,
whether they can ad-lib or not.
With this,
as I thought of a character,
I knew who could play it,
and I was calling them.
I said, "Do you want to be -- "
In fact, when I called Kerry,
who plays my late wife, I said,
"Oh, I've got an idea.
You play my dead wife."
And she went,
"What, you mean I'm a corpse?"
I went, "No, no, no.
No, you're not a corpse."
...some weird '60s sitcom.
But, yeah, it makes it --
it's nearly cheating,
because it makes it
so much easier,
and they're there from the
beginning, and you workshop it,
so it all looks so real.
The chemistry's good,
and it looks so natural.
-So you usually --
Historically,
you have done two seasons of
your shows and then a special.
This is a full third season
on Netflix.
I'm wondering, what was it about
this story that you wanted
to go a little bit further,
as far as number of episodes?
-It's slightly different.
It's not a traditional sitcom.
So I suppose it had
a more dramatic pace to it,
so there was a story to tell.
The themes are bigger --
life, death, you know,
mortality, grieving.
They were bigger.
I built up such an ensemble
of characters.
It was like a Springfield.
So I had a lot of
characters to sort of --
And it's only about an hour and
a half longer than those things.
It's only 18 half-hours,
which is not even
an American season.
That's not even a whole season.
They're going, "He did
18 episodes. What a trouper.
What a --
He should be given an award."
You know, so --
But yeah, those are the reasons.
And I loved it.
I absolutely loved it.
But it's still best
to go out on top.
It seems mad -- It seems mad
to end it now at its peak,
but I think ending it now
will mean it will last
for 10 years,
if you know what i mean.
It's always there.
It's a finite story.
And I just think --
It'll outlive me, definitely.
It'll definitely outlive me.
-This is a show,
like you mentioned --
It's about grieving.
It's about death.
Was that something
you were thinking about,
ruminating about
before you had this idea?
-No. It was really
a jumping-off point.
The idea was a guy
who'd lost everything
and didn't care about living.
He was gonna kill himself,
but the dog was hungry.
And he treated it
like a superpower,
like he could do anything
and then he could always
fall back on suicide.
And that was
the jumping-off bit.
But then it became
a sort of study in grief,
because after the first series
went out,
so many people came up to me
and they said,
"I lost my brother,"
or, "I lost my wife,"
or, "I lost my mother two weeks
before I watched,"
and you suddenly realize
that everyone's grieving.
People like seeing a bit
of themselves on the TV,
even if it's the bad stuff.
Especially if it's the bit that
people don't usually see on TV,
if it's a taboo subject
and not dealt with,
particularly if they see
the funny side of it,
because that's what comedy
is for,
for getting us over bad stuff.
And so I realized that people
really identified
with that side of it,
and I wanted to treat it
with respect,
because that's why he doesn't
just snap out of it, you know?
That's why it's a long struggle.
And it is about him
going through
the seven stages of grief.
It just asked the big question,
"If you lose everything,
is life still worth living?"
Without spoilers.
You need to find something
to make it worthwhile,
and that's what
he's looking for.
-When you're writing,
what part is most important
for you to tackle first?
Making it funny, which it is,
or also making it
sort of nail the landing
as far as the emotional arc?
Which one do you focus on more?
-Is it real? Is it honest?
Is it original?
Have I seen it on telly before?
Is it frightening?
All those things.
And when you think
of a great idea,
"Can I make it funny?"
And the answer is usually yes.
My stand-up is --
I talk about taboo subjects
because I want to take
the audience
to a place
it hasn't been before,
and I can feel it in the room.
When I bring up a contentious
subject, I can feel the tension.
It's like I take them by
the hand through a scary forest
and out the other side
and everything's alright.
Because there's nothing
you shouldn't joke about.
It depends on the joke.
And I've always thought that,
and I've always been fascinated
with that side of things,
because it's part of life.
We're all gonna die,
so let's joke about it.
Let's have a laugh.
-I know you've been doing
some stand-up again.
I want to talk about
your upcoming special.
We'll be right back with more
from Ricky Gervais.